[Music]
there are
basically three ways to gain acceptance
from someone
there are three ways that you can get
other people to accept you
and the first way
is how most of us try and it's actually
the most difficult
we buy expensive things or do things to
try to impress people we do things to
place us on a pedestal
so you will look up to me
and that is one way to gain acceptance
look at my lamborghini look at my big
house look at my fancy suit look at my
purse with all of the logos on it look
at these things they say something about
me i'm up here on a pedestal and
therefore
i'm valid to you
that's incredibly difficult but it's
even more difficult to sustain because
you buy a brand new
2022 lamborghini
and eight years from now it's an
eight-year-old lamborghini how
impressive is that so you have to keep
feeding the beast in order to remain
valid it's not a strategy that works
long term yeah the second way is to
place yourself on the same level as
someone else well how do you do that
well by listening
by conversing by being with
someone not convincing them not forcing
your ideas onto them but merely being
with them one might call it compassion
or empathy but what a great
a great step down
it's so much easier to get someone
else's acceptance by simply
listening to them by being there for
them and with them right i love it the
third way
is
to put yourself
below them
to serve other people
because if you really want acceptance
you don't need a lamborghini you don't
need a rolex you don't need a purse with
a bunch of logos on it
you can simply serve someone
you can help them because if you help
someone and they accept that help then
they're accepting you
for who you are
and here's the bonus fourth way
it's to
not need the acceptance at all ooh
because if i don't need your validation
your veneration i don't need you to
think a particular way about me then yes
i can still own the things i want to own
i don't need them to impress you anymore
i can still be with you because i want
to be with you but not because i need
your validation and then ultimately i
can still serve you
i can still help you
not because
you need me
but simply because
i need to help other people
and if i understand that
then i don't need your acceptance at all
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit
patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free